en indre-et-loire la circulation de
l'épidémie fléchi selon les derniers
chiffres de l'agencé régionale de santé
le taux d'incidence est passé sous la
barre des 300 cas pour 100000 habitants
sans doute les premiers effets du
confinement mais les autorités
sanitaires sont encore très prudentes
notamment pour les ehpad 15 cluster en
indre et loire 18 en loir et cher le
plus gros on vous en parle depuis le
début de semaine c'est celui depuis
gibeau à loches plus de cent quarante
résidents affectés en un mois très
autres sont morts alors comment
expliquer cette flambée des
contaminations dans cet établissement
éléments de réponse avec samuel colin 70
% des résidents positif et 13 décès en à
peine un mois la propagation du virus
est fulgurante dans l'ehpad épargné lors
de la première vague le site depuis
gibbons est désormais le plus grand
foyer de contamination du département
les soignants ne sont d'ailleurs pas
davantage épargnés un tiers des salariés
des femmes pour la plupart sont elles
aussi positive aux copies de 10,9
elles sont fatiguées elles se sentent en
fait tout seul au monde elles sont
malheureuses parce qu'elles peuvent pas
les accompagner jusqu'au bout comme elle
souhaiterait d accompagner parce que
parce que c'est pas possible encore
martys wars et une collègue qui s'est
retrouvé tout seul l'après-midi pour
trente résidents tout commence le 16
octobre
un soignant et testés positifs puis de
résident dans la foulée un protocole de
crise est mise en place
les visites des familles sont suspendues
les patients confinés dans leur chambre
pour limiter les brassages les
professionnels ont chacun leur secteur
et enfin tout le monde est testé tous
les sept jours
malgré cela le virus continue de se
répandre
une des explications avancées la
configuration même des lieux tous les
secteurs si vous voulez son communicant
et on a des résidents qui souffre de
démence et qui sont des ambulants et
bien entendu on ne peut donc ce n'est
pas éthique on ne peut pas enfermer les
gens dans
chants même si on les isole deux
patients sont hospitalisés au début de
la propagation
pour les autres résidents dont les 66
encore positif la prise en charge
médicale se fait sur place à l'ehpad
pour soutenir le personnel en
sous-effectif selon les syndicats des
renforts de médecin d'abord jusqu'à
trois praticiens à temps plein en ce
moment et une trentaine d'étudiants de
la croix-rouge et du chu de tours
aucune explication sur les
contaminations des soignants sinon que
le virus circule activement dans les
lieux la direction estime être arrivé au
plateau de l'infection et avoir encore
quinze jours difficiles à traverser les
familles elles peuvent continuer à
communiquer avec les résidents par
visioconférence